à thomas somare anne bonjour à tous
comme vous pouvez le voir nous sommes
aujourd'hui accompagné du célèbre
cavalier de ce rac khal drogo à celle de
le faire ouais tu parles que d'autres à
qui du coup n'ont as tu parle français
no ok je sens que ça va encore être
facile cette histoire nos bons si nous
sommes tous les deux réunis aujourd'hui
c'est pour aborder le sujet que vous
attendiez tous le structuralisme génial
et levi strauss
avant de commencer à parler de
structuralisme et d'anthropologie il
faut savoir qu'il ya un certain nombre
de termes qui vont poser problème mais
j'ai pas envie de m'appesantir dessus
pour le moment dans ce que je vais faire
c'est que je vais mettre au point une
petite boîte dans laquelle je vais
mettre tous les mots qui vont poser
problème et on reviendra dessus à la fin
alors pourquoi mettre en relation lévi
strauss et la série game of thrones à ce
propos je précise que cette vidéo est
absolument sans spoiler je ne raconterai
que des événements qui ont lieu dans la
saison 1 de game of thrones et si vous
n'avez toujours pas vu la saison 1 la
série nous présente une société
médiévale qui mise à part le côté
fantastique qui est assez discret dans
la saison 1 est assez proche des
sociétés médiévales européennes
l'histoire anglaise étant une source
vérifier d'inspiration pour l'auteur jr
martins qui s'inspire entre autres
choses de la guerre de cent ans et de la
guerre des deux roses et je vous
conseille un épisode du très barbu nota
bene si le sujet vous intéresse si la
série comporte de nombreuses créations
originales nul doute que notre bon vieux
georges s'est fortement inspiré de
l'histoire française et anglaise pour
construire son univers
nous nous plaçons notamment du point de
vue de west héros ce qui correspondrait
culturellement à notre europe avec de
nombreuses cultures comme les nordistes
la capitale port réal où la plus
éloignée cité de dornes mais on conserve
une certaine unité dans le
fonctionnement politique et dans la
langue
cela dit nous découvrons aussi à l'est
de l'ouest et ross le large territoire
des sceaux ce qui est alors composé de
culture beaucoup plus exotique pour le
feng shui de base et on y rencontre
notamment les deux tracks le peuple de
notre amicale drogo
les deux trains qui sont un peuple fier
et conquérant la langue gutturale très
proches de leurs chevaux et possédant
une organisation sociale très rigide par
rapport aux en dalle les habitants de
westeros voir la confrontation entre
deux cultures assez différente sera donc
un bon moyen de mettre en évidence les
structures sociales qui organisent la
vie entre les individus et donc
d'aborder le thème du structuralisme qui
nous intéresse aujourd'hui
la question sera donc comment comprendre
une société complètement différente de
la nôtre et plus généralement
mais c'est quoi le structuralisme nom
d'une pipette vermifuge
eh ben on y va
déjà le structuralisme c'est pas un gros
mot
c'est quoi j'avais déjà commencé à
aborder le sujet dans la première vidéo
en disant que j'y reviendrai plus tard
alors il ya quand même des chercheurs
qui ont essayé de montrer qu'il ya des
règles universelles qui régirait les
interactions humaines et qu'on pourrait
retrouver à n'importe quelle époque et
dans n'importe quel type de société
humaine mais ça on en reparlera quand on
parlera des structuraliste donc pas
maintenant et bien plus tard c'est
maintenant ici je parle de règles
universelles qui pourrait réagir toute
l'humanité on cherche donc une espèce
d'invariants culturelle que l'on
pourrait retrouver dans toutes les
sociétés humaines
je m'explique ce que disent les
structuralistes c'est qu'il ya de
nombreuses façons d'organiser la vie
humaine mais que ces différentes façons
ne sont pas infinies on a souvent
utilisé l'analogie du jeu de cartes
vous parlez des structures sociales et
humaines et société humaine étant comme
des cartes que l'on pourrait ré agencé
de toutes les façons imaginables
s'il ya en effet un très grand nombre de
combinaisons possibles
le fait qu'il y a un nombre fini de
cartes induit qu'il y ait un nombre
infini de combinaisons
il y à un autre des combinaisons qu'on
ne retrouvera jamais et d'autres que
l'on retrouvera très fréquemment au fil
des sociétés même si elles ne sont pas
obligatoires comme le patriarcat par
exemple
f il m'emmène slater mais justement je
ne pouvais pas faire une vidéo qui
traitent à la fois de game of thrones et
de structuralisme sans aborder un sujet
qui a fait couler beaucoup d'encre en
anthropologie l'inceste très rapidement
parce que c'est pas vraiment le sujet de
la vidéo mais l'inceste c'est quelque
chose qui a été abordé dans beaucoup de
récits anthropologique et qui est vu
comme une espèce d'invariants
structurale qu'on retrouverait dans la
plupart des sociétés tout où quasiment
tout là je vraiment je marche des oeufs
les sociétés ont une forme de
prohibition de l'inceste l'inceste
c'est pas bien après toutes les sociétés
ont leur façon de définir l'inceste il
ya beaucoup de sociétés ou c'est pas
bien de se marier avec sa soeur mais
avec sa cousine
il n'y a aucun souci mais bien sûr la
prohibition de l'inceste c'est la norme
sociale ça veut pas forcément dire que
tout le monde s'y conforment
nécessairement est justement cette
prohibition c'est le propre des sociétés
humaines et ne pas suivre certaines
règles humaine ça peut être justement
une façon de s'extraire de l'humanité
dans l'egypte antique par exemple il est
avéré que pour les pharaons il n'est
absolument pas inhabituel de besogner sa
soeur il faut bien voir que dans
l'egypte antique les phares ont été
considérés comme des dieux vivants et le
fait de déroger à la prohibition de
l'inceste serait donc une façon pour eux
de s'extraire de l'humanité pour
s'élever au rang de dieu et évidemment
pour tous les gens qui ont vu ne serait
ce que le premier épisode de game of
thrones savent très bien que l'inceste à
une place toute particulière dans la
série et là pour le coup c'est la forme
d'un c est la plus totale que l'on
puisse imaginer puisque c'est entre deux
frères et soeurs jumeaux et il y à bien
dans la série une prohibition de
l'inceste puisque cette intrigue est à
la base de la plupart des conflits qui
surviendront après ajouté au fait que
les lanester sont des nobles et qui sont
censés vivre selon des règles sociales
encore plus strictes que leurs
contemporains à retenir un peu dense est
bien dosé est une bonne idée
l'analyse structuraliste à la base elle
vient de la linguistique la langue étant
un élément structurant partagé par
l'ensemble des sociétés humaines et qui
définit en profondeur le rapport des
individus avec le monde
vez finissage irish et se laisse aussi
guerrero à john chick et comme le fait
remarquer notre ami de robots dans sa
langue si suave qui sont bons les
paillettes la camomille les petits
papillons tout mignon les deux rats qui
parle dans la série ne langue
particulière qui a été inventée exprès
pour eux qu il se trouve que notre ami
barbu linguistique way a fait une vidéo
experts sur le sujet donc je vous invite
à la consulter si le sujet vous
intéresse
allez-y c'est cool
la langue est un élément fondamental de
la communication humaine et il permet au
groupe de se penser comme communauté en
partageant un certain nombre de
signifiant sémantique on peut d'ailleurs
remarquer que ces langues inventées
comme le dothraki ont pu avoir une très
grande importance dans la constitution
originelle des communauté geek dans
certains groupes étaient capables de se
comprendre en parlant uniquement le haut
elle fit coup le klingon
pour notre part nous pouvons simplement
remarqué à quel point la langue est le
reflet de la culture à laquelle elle
prend pas c'est d'ailleurs exactement ce
qu'ont fait les créateurs de la langue
pour la série ils sont partis de ce
qu'ils savaient de la culture de trac
pour créer un vocabulaire et une
grammaire adaptés à leurs valeurs et à
leur mode de vie
présent dans l'esprit du match c'est une
façon générale il est évident que la
précision d'une langue dépend assez
fortement du mode de vie de ceux qui
l'utilisent
il ya par exemple une douzaine
d'expression pour dire le mot neige dans
la langue des inuits
alors qu'il n'y en a aucun en tahitien
de la même façon pour les deux trafics y
sont un peuple nomade et très attachés à
leurs chevaux leur vocabulaire se
construit très fortement autour de
l'équitation
bon on veillera à pas faire
d'essentialisme non plus pour reprendre
l'exemple des chevaux le mode road fera
date signifie chevauchées et les deux
rats qui sont donc le peuple qui
chevauche pour demander
veulent on dira donc à celle de frey gk
celle que l'on pourrait nous traduire
par salut comment vas tu mais qui se
traduit littéralement par as tu bien
chevauchée aujourd'hui plein de façons
pour dire au revoir on dira que cela
skate que l'on pourrait traduire par
chevauchent bien par définition l'homme
doivent chevauchées et celui qui marche
est vue comme inférieures la pire des
déchéances c'est donc tout naturellement
qu'on va retrouver le champ lexical de
la marche dans le registre des insultes
avec la très traditionnel insultes ne
fera qu il fasse maïs il gagne on
revient que marché est ravalé au rang d'
insulte et puis bon les mamans c'est un
peu le truc universel pour abc golfeur
de toute façon je non si c'est pas ça la
marque culturelle finalement méritée
palais
après avoir été théorisé en linguistique
le structuralisme sera surtout récupéré
par l'anthropologie et notamment par le
big boss badass de l'anthropologie lévi
strauss a et pour ceux qui pensent que
je parle d'une marque de jeans vous
pouvez sortir
lévi strauss est un anthropologue né en
1908 et qui a juste posé les bases de
l'anthropologie sociale pour faire le
lien avec ma précédente vidéo c'est
vraiment le continuateur des thèses de
durkheim d'une société aux listes la
différence de durkheim c'est que
durkheim il a passé toute sa vie à
bosser le cul vissé sur sa chaise dans
son bureau en travaillant sur des
données chiffrées alors que les bistrots
silva sur le terrain au contact des
sociétés et ouais mon gars en bonnet
fnaut log lévi strauss s'est donc
déplacé au coeur des sociétés qu'il
souhaitait étudier et il a notamment
observé des sociétés qu'il appelait
dites primitives
on dirait plutôt maintenant sociétés
sans écriture et ils cherchent sur leur
mode d'organisation comme les structures
de parenté ou l'étude de leurs mythes
fondateurs avec levi strauss le récit
anthropologique prend donc la forme de
carnet de voyage souvent raconté à la
première personne où le chercheur
raconte sa confrontation à d'autres
cultures
c'est notamment le cas d'un de ses
ouvrages qui reste le plus connu tristes
tropiques dans lequel il revient sur un
voyage de plusieurs années au brésil
dans game of thrones
on a typiquement ce type d' approche à
ceci près que l'anthropologue à des
bouts ce parce que la façon qu'on a de
découvrir la société d'autres accès par
les yeux de daenerys je vois la ligue 1
sa chevelure
quant à d'autres acquis et vaincu au
combat on lui coupe ça tresques que le
monde entier voit sa disgrâce
khal drogo n'a jamais subi une défaite
mais c'est un sauvage bien sûr mais
c'est l'un des meilleurs tueurs
actuellement vivant et tu vas devenir
celle qui est tout d'abord vendu dans
l'espoir que khal drogo fournisse une
arme et à son frère qui est plein
d'amour fraternel envers sa petite soeur
je laisserai la totalité de sa tribu te
baiser
l'ensemble de ces quarante mille hommes
et leurs chevaux aussi s'il fallait en
passer par là mais quel charmant
personnage
attendez on va se faire un petit kiff
une cour pour leur noir
à la bon l'aurez bien compris d'amneris
n'a pas vraiment le choix
et pour se faire accepter par la société
de son futur mari elle doit se
familiariser avec la culture de ce rac
et c'est lors de cet apprentissage
accéléré qu'elle adopte donc une posture
que l'on pourrait facilement comparer à
celle d'un anthropologue
en fait l'histoire de damien rice s'est
un peu les bistrots sur les dothraki
quoi qu'elle a priori any way enfin lady
strauss avec des boobs quoi et des
cheveux blonds et les dragons est un
papa qui veut brûler tout le monde je
sens que ma métaphore est en train de
m'échapper complètement à la différence
de lévi-strauss l'ineris ne se fait pas
une simple observatrice de cette société
une fois qu'elle en a compris les
fondements elle va tenter de la faire
évoluer
du moins elle va tenter de l'utiliser
pour la porter dans une direction qui
lui sera plus favorable
elle va essayer de profiter de sa
position de calais ici pour infléchir
certaines traditions comme le viol des
populations conquises qui n'est pas pour
plaire à tout le monde mais ça crée des
mécontents numérique choc
un cheminot cecci à nara lycée anna
hazare qui a laissé coaching canadian
akbou salle mungo il a tjrs sur getjar
il
comme une façon maggia jack in moscow
analogique adoration à sanaa
automoto rôle qui devait lancer
in the water qui est dit mais tu as
aussi les cannes et khwaja à licques et
molson sexy et les charolles et d'une
façon générale après la mort de son
frère elle va tout faire pour essayer de
convaincre son call de l'aider à
reconquérir le trône de westeros mais
elle se heurte alors à une barrière
culturelle qui fait que le concept même
de tron n'a pas lieu d'être dans la
culture de traquer les chevaux ce taux
qui bosse avec ça c'est dommage dans les
ti cats et sa tournée
mais ce rôle
drôme à dans le final qual nave sous les
jets à l'essai
caveau s'élevant à dromain evra sont les
aigris 77 on comprend cela dit que ce
n'est pas facile d'embrigader un peuple
entier dans un but qui n'a absolument
pas de sens pour eux alors qu'ils ont
déjà une organisation sociale très
développé les deux trains qui occupe la
région d'essen ce que l'on appelle la
mère de frac une vaste plaine où ils
font des raids réguliers avec leurs
capitales vice de trac où ils se
réunissent pour les grands événements et
dans laquelle il est interdit de faire
couler le sang
pour ce qui est de leurs croyances nous
avons déjà parlé de l'importance du
cheval dans leur culture
il est donc pas vraiment étonnant que ce
dernier constitue également une divinité
au même titre que la lune et le soleil
au passage on peut noter que quand un
guerrier mort ce fait les mollets la
tradition veut que l'on égorge et
incendies avec lui son cheval pour qu'il
y ait une monture sur laquelle atteindre
les cieux dans l'organisation sociale
des d'autres acquis un calme et sans
cesse
entouré de ses cent coureurs qui une
fois leur chef venger son sang c'est le
suivre dans la mort pour chevaucher
ensemble pour l'éternité
ils ont également des sortes de
superstition ainsi il est considéré
comme mauvais de toucher un mort sauf
pour celui qui l'a tué c'est assez
fréquent dans la plupart des cultures
d'avoir certaines coutumes visant à
mettre la mort à distance plus singulier
les deux pratiques craignent tout les
eaux qui ne sont pas consommés par leurs
montures
d'où leur répugnance pour l'eau salée et
donc le refus de principe de khal drogo
de franchir la mer mais bon quand on
s'appelle d'ein hérisson et halak a
gagné à camara qui sont analphabètes
mais rémy rally team honda ima neurones
à rima fakih rally team à la gauche
j'avance hiver ouais on va dire dan est
restée plus points quand on s'appelle
d'amneris on n'abandonne pas aussi
facilement et elle saura tirer partie
des traditions des d'autres acquis si
cette tradition existe elles ne sont pas
d'une fiabilité à toute épreuve et
cadres au bo fait justement partie de
ceux qui osent s'écarter de la norme
d'amneris va donc réussir partiellement
à obtenir ce qu'elle veut en faisant
appel à la masculinité à l'honneur de
focales mobile
non mes voyages c'est celle de dean à
d'autres académies de lyon me rabaisser
battre à ce qu'avait burqa la masse
à
till dawn of the squid and à coki pas
d'étudiants mustapha moundib haïti
karski viguier grâce à ma sauce
pathamathan
passons
casser les saf ananas au bas de la zone
bon et maintenant qu'on a bien expliqué
ce que c'était que l'anthropologie tu
m'explique que tu fais là oh merde
ostling à te laisser sa place à sow à
lille 28 de 9 à toi seul bon mais on a
fait une bonne petite introduction à
l'anthropologie on comprend un petit peu
mieux comment se pense la structure dans
l'organisation sociale
mais maintenant ça va être le moment de
regarder un peu tout ce qu'on a mis dans
notre petite boîte heures au quai paul
allou this avec le monde être précis
l'anthropologie c'est une discipline
problématique
tout simplement parce qu'elle est
racontée par des scientifiques qui sont
le plus souvent des occidentaux blanc et
les mâles et cela ne va pas sans un
certain degré d'haguenau centrisme où
tout ce qui n'est pas leur norme ou leur
culture devient tout soudainement
exotiques par là je veux dire que les
voyageurs ont souvent tendance à
considérer leur société comme la norme
voire pire comme un modèle inéluctable
vers lequel toute société est voué
attendre après une évolution suffisante
et c'est pour ça qu'on les a souvent
avec des sociétés primitives c'est parce
qu'elle ressemble à l'idée que l'on se
fait de nos propres sociétés dans le
passé fantasmé d'une ère pré
technologique
dans cette optique toute société
normalement constitué doit passer par
différents stades évolutifs obligatoire
le feu la roue l'écriture d'agriculture
l'argent le galetas l'isthme par les
deux sociétés primitives c'est
problématique parce que ça suppose une
certaine supériorité condescendante de
l'observateur sur l'observation et en
fait on a tout simplement à faire un
deux sociétés différentes et non pas à
deux stades différente d'une société qui
serait la société humaine revenons
maintenant à la notion d'essentialisme
que nous avions abordé et non c'est
toujours par le bromo mais là qui sort
l'essentialisme ce serait de considérer
qu'il ya une correspondance automatique
et où
à thouars entre les structures sociales
et l'individu et ne faut surtout pas
penser que les règles sociales sont
intemporels elles ont été inventées et
elles seront oubliées détourné
réinventer de la même façon on peut voir
dans la saison 5
car ouest et ross l'importance de la
religion est très variable en fonction
des époques
si elle est toujours restée en toile de
fond depuis longtemps on la voit revenir
sur le devant de la scène dans la saison
5 et 7 réémergence prend son origine
dans une intrigue politique
c'est dire à quel point des éléments
divers peuvent influencer à long terme
la direction que prendra une société
mais non c'est par un trailer de toute
façon un spoiler dans leurs démarches
loans c'est juste de révéler la mort
d'un personnage dont cet épisode de
sociologique est maintenant terminée je
vous invite à vous abonner à la chaîne
et à écrire dans les commentaires si
vous avez envie de partager vos
impressions sur le vase ce sujet qu'est
le structuralisme ou l'anthropologie
je remercie grandement gabriel qui m'a
aidé à écrire et à filmer un épisode
elle fera aussi partie de l'écriture et
de la réalisation du prochain qui ne lit
pas encore sur quoi tu es là surprise
et puis moi je vous dis à bientôt il ya
là pendant deux classes tchèque
cela dit et ça peut très bien réussir